I know you think you're a tough guy cuz
Strickland couldn't finish you. I'll
finish you. Don't worry about that. I'm
built different.
>> That's fine. The truth is more
important. I don't need to get approval.
I don't care. If there's something
incorrect happening to one of my
brothers, I'm going to go and speak up
for them. The first time you speak about
me is negative and trying to tear down
what I've brought to try to tear down my
career.
>> Sorry. With all due respect, under you
can't end nobody's career. The risk mean
the sustenance of God Almighty is in
God's hands. No one can come and try.
Don't let them say sorry. You can
attempt to. Yes, but you nothing.
Allah's will is going to reach that
person. And so those threats of angel
career, I'll do this. Please,
ladies and gentlemen from all around the
world. Today is Sunday, July the 27th,
2025. And we gathered here in South Gaza
Strip, most share our concerns about the
ongoing crisis in Gaza Strip. During the
humanitarian crisis that Gaza and his
people are undergoing,
food in general and flour, bread
especially, it's becoming luxurious and
rare. It's not available for the
citizens. So our mission here to support
the citizens and to help their their
lives to be better by giving them these
trips. On behalf of those citizens and
those families, we thank what forever
for his wonderful support. It will be a
reason and making the people happy.
Thank you for being a reason in this
effort.
[music]
Ever
la [music]
[music]
and sisters and dear friends fans okay
so there's been a beef that's happening
between Sneo and Andrew Tate uh And not
only that, Shafar has been trying to get
involved to say he can mediate and may
far has always been someone who's tried
to um you know do peace between
brothers. Alhamdulillah. Uh but we're
going to get there in Let's watch the
video straight away because um there's
some stuff I'm going to say that's going
to break a few people's heart in. So um
let's get straight into it. Here is the
reaction.
>> By Andrew's logic, white supremacists
are totally right. He should be kicked
out of Romania. You see how stupid that
is? Like why is Andrew trying to be a
white supremacist now when he's black?
Andrew Tate would be deported from
Romania following white supremacist
logic, but he's like, "I'm on your
side." No, you're not. You're literally
not on their side. Like, what? He says,
"I stopped talking to you years ago for
a reason." Okay. As if it's like God's
grace to speak. Okay? You know, you
didn't even respond to what I say. You
said that white supremacists are totally
right. I give a fair criticism based off
of Islam there. And you're like, "I
don't I don't like you. You're not on
the cool kids table." If that's what you
believe instead of Islam or instead of
what I'm talking about, then okay,
Andrew, nobody's botting likes. We're
watching the fight right now with Jake
Future. Nobody's botting likes, bro. See
my stream tomorrow night and address all
this. And I find that very childish like
what kind of response is that? And you
think you seem like a very logical man.
There's a lot of things that you say
makes a lot of sense and there's a lot
of things that you say like no damn
sense. One of them is this. Why you call
him oh you're gay. So what kind of reply
back he's like someone makes a logical
point and academic point. You're not
going to say oh I made it logical. Oh no
you're gay. Come on.
>> Explain this one because a few people
got confused including Sneo. And and
guys I know I've given him a hard time
right now but I'm not here to end Sneo's
career. I mean I could [laughter]
I'm that guy but I'm not here.
>> Sorry. With all due respect, Andrew, we
can't end nobody's career.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. Okay. You Sneo is
our brother. You are also our brother.
Uh but obviously I have more loyalty to
Sne because he's shown what he's really
about. And my Lord is Allan's messenger.
When I mean Sneo, I mean he follows
Quran and Sunnah. You sorry, let's be
question mark. You have caused riots
happen in the UK where Muslim women and
children and elderly have been attacked
and men. Yes. Because of your rhetoric.
Okay. Your lies. Three times you've
lied. Okay. And I've had some talk talks
with Andrew Tate circles. I'm not going
to go into detail. Yes, they have damn
loyalty to him, bro. They have hardcore
loyalty to him. So much so when they was
accusing me sadly of doing it for the
views and the fame and likes. I'm going
in my heart. How do you know? Subhan
Allah. It's unbelievable. Let's carry on
to do that to the guy. You know, he's
young. He's young. He'll get it. So, you
know, whatever. Sne has his view. The
only reason I haven't replied to him is
cuz he implied I was Jewish, which he
knows is a bit far. It's kind of
interesting. You know, I've always
noticed this about him. He's kind of
Okay, here. I don't know. I actually
messaged Nico. Let me see if it's
replied. Um, if it's Sne called a Jew,
no, he has on the prize probably.
Uh, let me make this very clear. Okay,
so
Sneo, you cannot call him a Jew. Yes, I
don't know what you meant by that. I
don't know if you meant ethnically Jew
or religiously Jew. If you mean
religious Jew bro that's you take him at
the p of Islam you have to be careful to
what you say I want to be just you're my
brother as well and you cannot call him
a Jew bro that's one you cannot call and
agitate a Jew if you meant ethnically
okay what does that mean so if it's
ethnically Jew so I wouldn't say that's
correct yeah I've been trying to contact
you just to ask you know what did you
mean by that but obviously you can look
I understand that in yeah that's wrong I
just take here is right
>> play them see if there's anything of
interest I'm half black and half white
let me confirm something race is real
it's super real I can literally turn my
black side or white side on like
choosing a different video game
character depending on the situation,
whatever is more advantageous at the
time. I can be white in the courtroom
and jail. I'm a hybrid, the ultimate
version of human, but most of you are
not hybrid. Most of you are one or the
other. The white supremists who say race
is everything are totally right. It is.
Ignoring race spells the end of the
white man, as the white man's complex
systems can be easily overloaded by
brutality. White people disagree, court.
High people disagree, kill. Stabbing is
easier than suing. It's not
>> racist. Everything is right. You're I
believe in Allah is everything. El
fought Not race, but his kind. Him being
a gin and Adam being is a different
creation. Yes. Okay. Cuz at least with
with white, black green, we're all the
same creation or the same human beings.
Well, they bleeds. They were different.
Totally different creation. Okay. And
for him, that was the main important
thing. And now you're here saying that
that is correct. That race is the most
important thing. No, it's not. Where'd
you get this from, bro? Bro, where you
get this red from? I'm so sorry.
>> All right. But it's fast. It's quick.
It's efficient. And efficiency wins in
the end. White people systems work with
white people. Suing only works when
suing is the only option. Bottom line,
ignore race at your peril. India is
India because they're Indians. Norway is
Norway because they're Norwegian. You
can argue all day about where's better
and where isn't. But that is the facts.
As a white person, it must be brutally
frustrating to see a huge percentage of
white people betray their own people.
Also frustrating to see people come to
white countries and on the natives
all day. But perhaps white people
deserve it for allowing so many white
traitors to encourage it.
>> What the hell are you talking about?
What is the most racist thing I've
heard? Disagree with a black person he
kills with the white person is cool.
Who's committed the most genocide,
massacre, killing of millions of people
around the world? With those you
respect, it's been the white people. I
mean, when I mean white, I'm not saying
everybody is simple white. It's the
white man. So, what are you talking
about, bro? Bro, you have an obsession
with white and white supremacy. I don't
know why is in the infirmity complex,
bro. You're half black, half white. Why
are you not so proud to be of your black
side, bro? You only use your black side
when it takes as an advantage towards
you. That's bro, it's so bizarre. Why
are you so obsessed? I want to know why
is he so obsessed with being white.
>> Traitors are the worst. They inspire
your enemy. History has always hated
rats and traitors for this very reason.
They're worse than the enemy itself. The
word racist has cuped the white man into
surrendering surrendering their lands
and their women forever. The word racist
has turned a large majority of whites
into traitors. The white in me feels bad
for you. Me is riding around with white
women in Lambos. It is what it is. But
race is real. And white supremists are
totally right about this. No white only
country means soon there will be no
white people.
>> What are you talking about? Who's been
going to other people's countries and
bombing and killing, massacring,
stealing the wealth and the resources of
those lats?
Are you okay though? You're you're a
smart guy. Are you playing dumb when it
comes to white supremacy? You're so
obsessed with Are you playing dumb? Huh?
What are you going to do? Challenge me
to a boxing fight? What are you going to
do? Huh? Send me location.
>> You'll be out bred. You'll be out
violenced. You'll be cuffed by words.
You'll be betrayed by your own kind. And
I am not your enemy for pointing this
out. I am your brown friend confirming
you were right all along. But unlike
you, I cannot be called racist to any
serious effect. That was the
>> race is real and racism is real and
you're a fine example of that. I'm your
brown friend. Andrew, you'll be the
trust me. You might be the last on the
boat, but you're going to be on the
boat, my friend. Okay? Don't think
they're going to keep you there. You're
half black. Yes. Okay. They're going to
say, "Listen, listen. You're the low
race. Okay? Get they'll hate you more.
The fact that your your mother your dear
mother married your father. Yes. They're
they're going to hate her. They're going
to hate you, bro. You're an emperor that
they're going to hate you. Now, when I
said this, Sneo, a few others got
confused. I'm like, he's a white
supremacist.
>> Got that right.
>> Okay, let's see what Sneo had to say.
Shut up.
>> Wrecked because you deserved it. Cuz you
can't call me a Jew. And also, just
because you've been Saudi and I've been
trapped on house arrest, you don't get
to be a better Muslim than me and tell
me how the world works either, friend.
Right. So no hard feelings but you
served it right. You said in person I
would have knocked your ass out and I
would have helped you get up afterwards
and said sorry. Sorry I had to break
your jaw. Sometimes things just have to
happen you know.
>> Yeah. Sorry. You said that you was on
house. So how come you went to flipping
California or whatever it was going and
gambling all that kind of stuff but you
can't go to Sabi. So you can go
everybody can please don't make excuses
for us. Okay. Don't make excuses like
this. Okay. Not only that you say that
oh you knock sne etc. Listen.
Yeah. Nobody will touch him. Okay. No
one's going to touch him, bro. Okay?
Just the way we we defended you. Okay?
When these allegations were made against
you, which Allah, we defended you,
Andrew. Okay? So, you need to
understand, you can't come here tell
threaten people and say, "Look, look,
I'm I'm I'm not I'm not like I do box
here and there, etc. Yeah, you're a
fighter. Yeah, we know people who can
knock your jaw out. Those respect, we
know people who can knock your jaw out."
Well, it might not be me. So, let's not
talk about this because you're a Muslim
to another Muslim and it's not nice.
Talking about threat behavior, etc. It's
not nice. Okay. Uh so, please let's
let's not act this intellectual
distortion. Let's give intellectual.
>> I know you think you're a tough guy cuz
Strickland couldn't finish you. I'll
finish you. Don't worry about that. I'm
built different. But guys, don't pile on
sneak. I he supported me in my case. Of
course he did because I'm innocent and I
would support him if he had a case and
he's young and he will get one cuz he's
very young and if he continues to run
around with all them women, he's going
to get a case and I'll support him the
same. Of course he will. You can't call
me a Jew.
>> I mean you want to give it to Sneaker.
He did it. It's a wife sugar. They did
fantastic. Yeah. But regarding this
case, oh, you will get a case. Well,
alhamdulillah. In Islam prevents that in
Islam. If you get married, you won't be
going around sleeping around girls who
come and accuse you like falsely. Yes.
Okay. So, yeah, that wouldn't happen. So
if which he is alhamdulillah he would to
protect himself from that he doesn't
need your defense of once it happens
you're going to defend him or these no
no he's got what is going on
>> that's fine the truth is more important
I don't need to get approval I don't
care if there's something incorrect
happening to one of my brothers I'm
going to go and speak up for them but
very clear what everybody sees you have
not acknowledged any of that you've
never said a word of anything positive
the first time you speak about me is
negative and trying to tear down what
I've brought to try to tear down my
career in fact you said that you were
going to end my career that you want to
end everything that I've built that's
the first intelligence from the person
probably the most famous person in my
generation by far who's the day one when
you got locked up. It was me. You're
innocent. You're This is incorrect. This
is unjust. The only one. In fact, I
THINK I DESERVE credit for helping your
reputation with Gen Z. WHO ELSE WAS
REALLY SAYING THIS? I LOVE AIDEN. And I
think
>> this here is interesting because he
talking about ending career, but you
can't you can't in no one's career. That
the risk the risk mean the sustenance of
God Almighty is in God's hands. No one
can come and try. Let me say something.
You can attempt to Yes. But you don't
nothing. Allah's will is going to reach
that first. So those threats of I will
end your career. I'll do this. Please
think you you've been disrespectful as
well. But a lot of people were quiet. A
lot of people didn't say a word because
they didn't want to risk reputation in
case that you were actually guilty, but
I was there. And then the first time you
say anything is you're gay. I stopped
talking to you for a reason. People see
through this. People see through this.
It doesn't bother me. It doesn't bother
my community, the audience. But people
are going to see through this and it's
going to damage your reputation as the
beacon of truth, the beacon of
masculinity. You're like, "What? Wait,
what about brotherhood? What about
loyalty? What about truth?" All what
does even say to make you this upset?
WHAT DOES SNEO say to trigger you to
diss him publicly and then make a whole
stream correcting him and threatening to
saying you want to fight, saying you
want to end my career, to be boastful
and prideful? In fact, the arrogance
that everybody is seeing from this is
proof that maybe people are going to
start looking in different directions.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP THE BRAND OF TOP G,
YOU CANNOT HOLD ON TO THIS arrogance and
pride that you so clearly have.
>> I mean, he's right. This is nons
behavior, but people can see through it.
Like, you are acting weak. You're acting
emotional when you're calling names. UK,
you're this. I'm not pure. I'll end your
career. These are all personal attacks.
Deal with the deal with what he's
saying. And it seems that Andrew, you
don't like to be wrong. And when you're
called that when you're wrong, you hate
it. End your career. I'll get physical.
You're gay. Come on, bro.
>> I'm not saying this to disrespect, but
it's it's become evident to a lot of
people because real masculinity is not
being boastful. Real masculinity is NOT
BEING PRIDEFUL. REAL masculinity is not
flashiness and cars AND LOOK HOW STRONG
AND RICH I AM. MONEY DOES not make your
masculinity. In fact, it's the opposite.
>> Exactly. I mean, that's exact.
Especially in Islam, there's many
examples where Red Brothers have to shut
their mouth. They have to shut their
mouth. That's a white supremacist belief
and that is incorrect. That's a lie.
That's not true. In fact, it goes
against the very fundamentals of Islam.
So I tweeted I said white supremacists
are totally right. This goes against the
core fundamentals of Islam. God did not
in fact choose any race to supreme. And
if you believe so, you're Jewish. Saying
if you believe that there's a supreme
race, you follow the Zionist ideology
that's creating all the destruction of
the world. You are following the belief
system that's contributing to the
genocide of Palestinians right now. Free
Palestine.
>> Okay. Okay. I hear you out. I know what
you're trying to say. But kind of
logically doesn't follow, bro. You
cannot come and say, "Bro, just because
he believes in a specific supreme race
theory, whatever just because that is
shared with Zionist, therefore he's a
Jew." I don't think that's fair because
you could agree um you could say
something for example say and
what can I say? Um I could agree with
something that Zionist I can't from the
top of my head. Yeah. Okay. That doesn't
mean I'm I'm a Jew or I'm a Zionist.
Okay. So I would say that's unfair to
say that it does not make him a Jew or
make him a Zionist. Yes. They both have
supreme things where they you know look
down on the goi you know and they try to
interesting what you mentioned here but
yeah to say that he is a Jew or is
Zionist is you can say they share those
things you know there's a there there's
correlation there but you cannot come
and say you know that is he makes him a
Zionist that's that's not fair
>> there is no supreme race God did not
choose anybody to be better than anybody
else that's why Islam exists Islam
exists to get rid of that racial barrier
so I corrected him if you believe that
you're better than other people you are
following Zionist ideology in fact
that's a guy ideology that everybody
else is greet everybody else subhuman
animalistic everybody else is worse and
that they can do things to the rest of
the world that they don't do between
themselves for example they won't
practice usery between themselves but
they're practicing with the rest of the
world they won't do gambling they won't
do they won't share porn
>> people so they you can say they are
following Zionist ideology but don't say
they're a Jew that's that's not right
you're okay but you're right in this way
you're right
>> I don't I DON'T LIKE I'M GOING TO DO YOU
THINK IT'S CRAZY TO me that he thinks
I'm scared and that you think I'm scared
of you no Muslim is scared of another
MAN WE ONLY FEAR ALLAH WHAT CAN YOU SAY
what can you what do you think you can
do that's going to that's going to like
make me live in fear.
>> Exactly. Alhamdulillah, we fear Allahh
and no one else. And this is the last
clip in
>> like siding with these people that are
stirring up riots in the UK. That will
happen again if you side with white
supremacy. It I don't want to see that
mistake being repeated. I've met some of
these people too. I just came back from
the UK. I know what happened. And it's
just like a very simple thing that we
need to correct. So, you know, I wish
the best for for my Muslim brothers. I
think he, you know, he took it
personally. Yeah,
>> I'm I'm going to put this out there. If
our brother tape wants to have like a
offline conversation with Nico, myself,
and him and kind of discuss everything
out, he's our brother. We'll solve it.
But, you know, we cannot sight with
people who are spreading lies that are
physically harming Muslims, right? This
is this is not acceptable. The Quran and
the Sunnah keep us united and, you know,
going into our own sid tracks divides
us.
>> Yeah. We can't And yeah, that's it. And
that's true. Is there to help brothers
to reconciled and this is the hug in it
seems like Andrew T has a lot of lot of
loyalty to his rights of prison then
Islam with respect it comes across and
I'm not saying that makes him a cap. I'm
not saying that. I'm just saying he's
got his loies in the wrong places and I
just and I think that's because it
doesn't take Islam seriously. I gen take
Islam seriously. But anyways guys what
can I say in nothing else can be said.
I'll leave this matter sisters to you
guys. Alhamdulillah Allah the best of
hope this matter is resolved. But um
yeah nothing else can be said. do not
forget to donate to the link in to help
our bonist in Gaza who are suffering and
the least we can do is that and we ask
Allahh to forgive us that we have done
enough for them that we are not about
this
very